Laxton he'll wanna Blackston hill farms
now what why and how would you describe
the lieutenant he works for Hawkins he
put the money in the accounts
Melanie Hawkins was the most honorable
cop I ever worked with and the only
reason I am here is because of that man
Jake Peralta
he offered me $300,000 to lie and say
that she set him up okay
okay this is bad this is really bad but
just remember we are not going to jail
we didn't do it innocent guilty on all
charges
[Music]
cool cool cool cool cool cool
this suggested plan reduces our overall
budget by 35% and it contains very
practical deep cuts in many of our
services Leslie this is amazing but it's
moot why our investigation has revealed
that things in Pawnee are much worse
than we anticipated meaning what well
effective tomorrow morning the entire
government will be shut down until
further notice I'm sorry I just started
hearing really loud circus music in my
head what did you say I don't understand
that after 15 years of service here I
have to get in the car and drive to New
York in order to talk to you that
doesn't seem right to me that doesn't
seem fair and I think that I've earned
more than that yeah
you're right yes I get it I get it
Michael okay here's what I'm gonna do
okay we will move some money around and
I will personally see to it that you
have your party you have your figs I
will be in attendance it's gonna be
great how's that
all right quit what Michael you have no
idea how high I can fly squad if I could
have your attention please
I'm being transferred to the public
relations office I'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately hell I
don't understand what the hell why are
you doing this what the hell I want to
say it has been a pleasure to have
worked alongside all of you for the past
twenty one and a half months I'm sorry
for getting so emotional pretty
consistent tone actually these have been
uh these have been the best years of my
career no no this is new and I know that
every one of you give me everything you
had
and I will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me eat more see dismissed sir I'm coming
with you
Thank You Gina I'm also coming not
necessary
hi guys
this is where a lot of faces its
toughest test after this just smooth
sailing for the rest of our lives
Holly will you marry me
No very me Holly no that guy's got more
that he can handle as it is will you
marry me you know that marriage would be
a sham you marry me
No easy now will you marry me no that
would be hot I'd pay to see that will
you marry me Holly
No only one that I was kind of worried
about
this is where I fell in love with you
and this is where I asked you to marry
me
it started
[Music]
[Laughter]
Holly flax marrying me will you be
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're moving to Colorado all of us yep
wait what Holly has to go back to
Colorado I'm going with her I'm leaving
holy mother for King shirt boss what Wow
okay well yo Mikey Shawn come on
is everything okay right as rain Mikey
my boy so Judy and I are gonna go to the
bad place what trust me
I've got this that's our decision let's
hit it
Oh what about realllly no it's me and
cheating call the train point of order I
don't accept this offer the real
mistakes were Jason and Ella you said
any two of us it's me and Sheedy let's
do it to it Michael I just found an
obscure precedent in the rules that
might just save everyone buzz off Bamba
John don't need it huh okay
ready when you are boss Eleanor what's
going on it took me a while to figure it
out but just now as we were all fighting
and yelling at each other and each one
of us demanding we should go to the bad
place I thought to myself man this is
torture and then it hit me
they're never gonna call a train to take
us to the bad place they can't because
we're already here this is the bad place
oh I can't believe you figured it out oh
yeah you're you ruined everything you
know that
hey hey how's it going good
especially after I took all your money
in poker yeah hey about when you want to
give me more your money did you wanna do
that now we can go inside feeling kind
of good tonight
I was just um
I'm in love with you
what I'm really sorry if that's weird
for you to hear but I need you to share
it
probably not good timing I know that I
just what are you doing
could he expect me to say to that
I just need you to know
once
well I
I
I can't
yeah
you have no idea don't about what your
friendship needs to be
I don't want to do that I want to be
more than
I can't
I'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
it's probably my fault
not her fault
I'm sorry I misinterpreted our
friendship
you